uh i have to say uh jessica that it took
me like uh like a minute to get past the
sort of prosthetics and makeup while
watching this movie but i want to know
how long did it take you as the person
behind it all to get past it to be able
to sort of do what you wanted to do
well excuse the the
pun but it was like a leap of faith for
me
it really was after the very first test
i had some nerves because i mean the
work was so beautiful that they created
but i thought how am i going to act
through it it's i've never acted before
i mean even like to not be able to feel
air on your skin and she was such this
open
like beating heart with no
you know um protection no armor and now
i have something on top of me
am i going to be able to go through it
and i you know it took a couple pep
talks like a good a talk with my good
friend david greenbaum at searchlight um
and i just was like you know what i'm
just gonna show up as big as i can and
i'm gonna make my way through this
makeup and i realize at the end of the
day it helped me more than anything
was there a level of self-consciousness
that you had that maybe you hadn't had
in a very long time
oh yeah i mean
there's nothing about tammy that's very
cool you know she's not alone
so a lot of the characters
you know i i have played i played a lot
of different characters i mean celia
foote isn't cool or lube
but um
[Music]
it's easy it's it's less embarrassing to
kind of be like leaning back a bit but
like when you're putting when you're
laying it all down on the table the
accent the singing the pitch of my voice
the costumes like the humor the you know
the silly little campy things that she
did with and and i was just worried it
was going to become a caricature like
how do i really show this woman
but also celebrate all these things
about her
yeah that was it was very self-conscious
and those hours with you and andrew in
the chairs together in those trailers
getting it all done
was were you talking were you goofing or
were you two separate human beings just
trying to fight your way through it what
did you do to sort of lighten the mood a
little bit or could you
yeah but i mean but also too we kind of
made the energy of tammy and jim you
know we would we used that time to do as
much like
i had watched every single thing i could
possibly find on her but it was like
okay we're going to do this scene today
let's find
let's see what we can find from ptl
footage or on youtube or
through you know the unused footage of
the documentary like let's see what we
can look at to inspire us from the scene
for the scenes today so we used it as
like prep before each day
yeah and i'm looking at you right now
and i'm like tammy would have loved that
top honestly and and the the pants it's
like full leopard all for tme today
is there still a little bit do do you
keep a little bit of the characters when
you're done with them and what are you
going to keep about tammy uh
i do i think because in some sense
every time i play a character even if
they're very different from me i find a
seed of related you know something i can
relate to and i like plant it and then
grow it inside me
so
there are things that i connect to with
tammy and
um
you know she just
it was so important for her that
everyone felt important around her and
loved and deserving of love and worthy
of god's grace and so
that's something i mean i i believe that
as well and and hopefully she inspires
me
to
remember that when when i meet people
this is the kind of role and performance
that people immediately start talking
about oscar how does that make you feel
i can't like think anything like that
because the reality honestly this is all
i'm thinking right now the movie is
premiering today after 10 years of
of like wanting to make it and i am
so nervous i am so stinking nervous that
the audience is going to be i have never
seen it with an audience because we
edited it during covid
and quarantines i am so nervous like i
can't even think to the future i just
hope people like the film
really you are wonderful in it thank you
so much for your time congratulations
thank you very much
you